just like Lady Liberty all the stars and
stripes a mouthful of perfect pearly
whites
screams USA in fact Americans spend more
than 111 billion dollars on their smiles
every year and it's inspiring the rest
of the world to dig deep into their
pockets to here's how America got such
pretty teeth
[Music]
the sound of the dentist's drill is
enough to keep Plenty away but the
global industry for cosmetic dentistry
is growing fast straightening and
reshaping are increasingly popular and
whitening products are now easily
available off-the-shelf worth nearly 16
billion dollars in 2015 the cosmetic
dentistry market is expected to hit
nearly 28 billion by 2024 and while
cosmetic dentistry is big all around the
world its most famous in America where
it all began specifically Hollywood or
Hollywood land as it was known back then
in the 1930s American cinema was booming
after the silent era sound was
introduced which meant stars suddenly
had to bare their teeth this would have
a dramatic effect on the industry and an
even bigger impact on dentistry one
movie girl was a dentist and his name
was Charles Pincus Pincus had recently
moved to Hollywood and he sensed an
opportunity in the movies the camera is
cruel in its relentless exposure of the
smallest floor in the mouth a tooth
turned even slightly out of line cast
the shadow brought Pincus in an essay to
fellow dentists
Pinkus had connections in the industry
the maxfactor family who were already
revolutionising makeup for the movies
needed his help in the studio for actors
of that generation makeup wasn't enough
the notion of oral hygiene was barely in
its infancy Pincus invented snap-on caps
that cover crooked or missing teeth made
out of powdered plastic and porcelain
they became known as Hollywood veneers
among his patients he countered Joan
Crawford and James Dean one of his
greatest achievements though was
probably the youngest of them all she's
been a leading lady from the start
despite featuring in hits since she was
6 years old
audiences would never see Shirley Temple
lose a single baby tooth that was thanks
to pincus's veneers after all stopping
filming for a missing tooth would cost
tens of thousands of dollars moviegoers
were wowed by the perfect smiles of
their favorite stars having good teeth
became an aspiration but despite that
developing into a near national
obsession with perfect teeth Americans
don't actually have the healthiest teeth
nearly 1 in 5 older than 65 doesn't have
any teeth at all and that might be
because of access to health care of
those who didn't visit the dentist last
year 59 percent claimed cost as the top
reason when countries are ranked by how
few fillings or missing teeth they have
the u.s. doesn't make the top ten in
joint first is actually the British
despite what everyone thinks well since
you've been frozen there have been
fabulous advances in the field of
Dentistry what do you mean
while Americans might not have the
healthiest of teeth having the
best-looking might be just as important
Americans spend more each year on beauty
than they do on education but it's not
pure vanity it's an investment
attractive people tend to earn more
appear more healthy and more likely to
marry making teeth good for our health
bleh
[Music]
you